president biden spoke by phone with
china's president xi jinping for more
than two hours yesterday amid growing
tensions over taiwan mr biden reaffirmed
the u.s policy on taiwan has not changed
while xi warned that quote those who
play with fire will perish by it
china is upset over a possible visit to
taiwan by house speaker nancy pelosi
next month cbs news adam yamaguchi is in
taiwan with more on this part of the
story adam good morning to you
good morning
the taiwanese government had been paying
very close attention to the call and
issued a statement thanking the biden
administration for its rock-solid
relationship and continued support for
taiwan security all this comes during a
tense moment felt across the island
it's taiwan's annual military muscle
flexing
a multi-day live fire exercise preparing
their response to a potential chinese
military invasion we watched land
exercises simulate a chinese attempt to
take over taipei's harbor so this is all
a very very critical position here you
see that giant port back there that is
what the chinese want to capture
onboard a coast guard vessel we saw just
how little water separates taiwan from
mainland china a major route for
international trade and u.s naval ships
only 80 miles
wow
china claims this self-governing island
as its own and has increased both its
military pressure and rhetoric in recent
months while closely monitoring world
reaction to russia's invasion of ukraine
this year's exercise also includes air
raid drills the population here is on
edge
and getting prepared
locals here express relief over
america's continued support in the face
of what they see as an ever-growing and
looming threat across the strait
for cbs morning's adam yamaguchi taipei